[Musique]
est-ce qu'il est normal encore
aujourd'hui d'avoir un accès qui soit si
difficile d'avoir accès à un médecin et
ou un professionnel de santé
est-ce que c'est normal d'attendre des
heures à l'urgence ou d'attendre par
exemple pour une chirurgie pendant des
années
c'est quoi la réponse la réponse est non
question du B sur l'état du réseau de la
santé au Québec et l'importance
d'adopter sa réforme une nouvelle agence
plus de flexibilité des infirmières des
spécialistes aussi est-ce que c'est la
clé d'un succès que tant d'autres avant
lui ont été incapables d'obtenir on va
voir ce qu'on pense les collaborateurs
cette semaine c'est Hugo la vallée notre
analyse à Québec qui est avec nous à ses
côtés Chantal Hébert chronicard au
Toronto Star et au magazine de
l'actualité Michel seoget une coop
politique Radio-Canada et la presse
bonjour à vous trois bonjour bonjour
commençons avec vous quelles sont les
chances de réussite de Monsieur Dubé
là c'est toute une question évidemment
monsieur Dubé a quand même certains
atouts dans son jeu évidemment faut pas
oublier que Gaétan Barrette lorsqu'il
avait pris la fonction de ministre de la
Santé c'était déjà un personnage
controversé en cause de son passé à la
Fédération des médecins spécialistes du
Québec là-bas monsieur Dubé évidemment
une cote de popularité très importante
le contexte politique aussi évidemment
est différent de ce qu'on a connu par le
passé bien sûr il y a eu la pandémie ça
exacerbait l'impatience des Québécois
face au réseau donc on a l'impression
que s'il y a des gens qui tentent de
mettre trop de sable dans l'engrenage ça
risque de mal passer quand même faut pas
sous-estimer évidemment l'ampleur du
défi qui se pose devant Monsieur Dubé
évidemment cette réforme là parce que
c'est le vrai mot là c'est une réforme
et toute une réforme même si le
gouvernement souhaite pas trop utiliser
ce mot-là pour pas apeuré les électeurs
c'est le gros morceau du Plan Santé du B
et là où il y a eu le projet de loi sur
les agences de placement il y a eu aussi
évidemment le partage des informations
mais là on rentre dans le cœur du sujet
ce qui fait aussi une grosse différence
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire il va
avoir l'appui de son premier ministre et
là encore ça se distingue de Gaëtan
barrette à deux égards
faisait pas partie des amis de la maison
et ça a apparu et ensuite Philippe
Couillard qui était lui-même un médecin
spécialiste clairement avait une oreille
à un endroit et l'autre sur son ministre
de la santé tandis qu'on sent que que
Monsieur Dubé a nettement davantage
carte blanche François Legault se
réveille pas le matin avec des atomes
crochus avec ses anciens collègues
médecins spécialistes ou autres Michel
qu'est-ce qui fait en sorte d'après vous
que Monsieur Dubé peut ou un une chance
de mieux faire que ces prédécesseurs
il doit réussir deux choses et deux
choses qui sont pas évidentes la
première c'est de convaincre les gens
qu'une réforme qui est essentiellement
administrative va donner de meilleures
services
le lien est pas facile à faire le lien
logique est pas là c'est pas automatique
alors ça c'est la première des choses et
c'est la plus importante la deuxième
c'est qui doit éviter ce qui a été le
piège dans lequel le docteur barrette
est tombé et c'est à dire de donner
l'impression qu'il avait l'unanimité
contre lui
à l'époque souvenez-vous la réforme
barrette au tout début a été populaire
c'est un peu comme aujourd'hui on disait
ça va tellement mal il faut faire
quelque chose on va essayer ça mais ça
n'a pas fonctionné parce qu'à la fin il
y avait tout le monde contre lui permet
comment ça se fait que personne qui
t’appuie là-dedans et ça c'est un danger
qui guette monsieur Dubé écoutez depuis
que aussi je peux remonter il y a pas eu
un premier ministre au Québec qui avait
gagné le bataille contre le syndicat des
infirmières
Bourassa l'évêque nommé de tous alors
les infirmières ça fait partie des gens
qui dans le système hospitalier sont
populaires des gens les aiment les
infirmières et trouve qui sont pas bien
payés pour tout le travail qui font etc
alors il faut qu'il affronte tout ce
monde là ça va être beaucoup moins
ouais il y a pas un politicien au Canada
qui a gagné une bataille contre les
infirmières c'est pas seulement faut pas
le prendre personnelle au Québec il y en
a pas vous avez couvert comme moi
l'Ontario et vous vous souvenez de des
conflits avec les infirmières c'est
perdu d'avance la vérité c'est que
effectivement Christian Dubé doit les
mettre dans son camp
les négociations avec les médecins
s'annoncent pas plus facile sauf que
avec les médecins depuis 10 ans
l'opinion publique a un peu changé de
côté c'est-à-dire que la perception du
médecin qui quand il s'exprime a
forcément raison
le ministreur c'est fini l'époque papa a
raison ou docteur raison donc de ce
côté-là il va avoir l'opinion publique
de son côté quant aux côtés
administratif la réforme et ça c'est un
peu un piège pour l'opposition parce
qu'on peut faire une bataille à
l'Assemblée nationale sur qui va décider
qui centralise qui centralise pas les
gens vont juger avec raison aux
résultats c'est-à-dire est-ce que tout à
coup ça prend moins de temps est-ce que
l'urgence fonctionne mieux ils vont pas
aller voir si le troisième patron du
quatrième étage qui a été déplacé
fonctionne mieux pour le système
qu'auparavant et c'est vraiment deux
débats dont un touchent pas directement
l'opinion publique franchement le mot de
la fin sur ce sujet
effectivement ce qu'il faut noter aussi
dans ce cas-ci par rapport aux
infirmières et aux médecins c'est que
Monsieur Dubé quand même le oui il y a
eu beaucoup de critiques cette semaine
il y a quand même eu des points plutôt
positifs des mots plutôt positifs de la
part de l'Ordre des Infirmiers
infirmières et du Collège des médecins
du Québec le même président du cmuq dans
certaines entrevues disaient c'est vrai
que peut-être certains médecins qui
doivent en faire davantage un des gros
point d'interrogation c'est que va faire
le président de la Fédération des
médecins spécialistes du Québec docteur
Olivon on le connaît pas encore beaucoup
là il est là depuis quelques temps mais
il est plutôt passé sous le radar là ça
va un premier véritable affrontement
pour lui avec le gouvernement alors ce
qui va prendre la même posture que celle
de sa prédécesseur Diane Francart
l’impression que c'est peut-être un peu
moins son genre qu'il veut peut-être un
peu plus travailler en coulisses en tout
cas on verra bien pour ce qui est de
Monsieur Dubé aussi est-ce qu'il veut
vraiment faire adopter tout ce qui est
dans le projet de loi ou est-ce qu'il
faut plutôt le voir peut-être comme un
point de départ pour justement amorcer
le dialogue ou amorcer des diffusions
sur certains sujets d'ailleurs monsieur
Dubé il disait cette semaine c'est assez
intéressant il a comme par avance
dédouaner les syndicats les fédérations
médicales en disant vous direz ce que
vous voulez sur la place publique
l'homme et gardez avec moi un canal de
communication ouvert et donc dans ce
contexte là c'est peut-être justement la
voix de passage qui voit on connaît
monsieur Dubé c'est un style bien
différent de Monsieur barrette il est
moins dans la confrontation publique en
tout cas et il a du temps devant lui
pour faire avancer les choses bon
changeons de sujet parce que l'autre
élément qui est retenu l'attention
beaucoup cette semaine c'est un homme
Freeland un budget un budget qu'on avait
qualifié en tout cas on avait pensé ou
imaginer avec un peu plus de restreinte
et ça c'est pas en vérité que ça Michel
comment vous l'avez vu le budget d'abord
un des investissements dans trois c'est
très ciblé et l'élimination du retour à
l'équilibre budgétaire ça a surpris un
peu cette semaine
ça surpris et mais il faut pas oublier
qu'on est le seul pays du G7 qui en
avait encore des sites de retour
[Musique]
et quand on se compare on se console
cela dit il y a beaucoup de dépenses il
y a des dépenses là-dedans qui sont
structures et qui sont probablement pas
une mauvaise idée le 80 milliards pour
les nouvelles technologies puis
l'économie verte si on ne le fait pas
ils vont le faire l'autre côté de la rue
aux États-Unis on risque de partir
beaucoup de ça on a vu cette semaine qui
était financier du Parti libéral du
Québec dire on devrait peut-être faire
ça au Québec nous autres parce que
franchement on va être en retard alors
ça c'est structures on verra si c'est
bien dépensé puis ça fonctionne bien ça
c'est structure là par contre il y a des
choses qui sont moins moins
intéressantes quand on voit par exemple
le
ce qui est le prix à payer pour avoir la
plus jeune ça donne dentaire dans les
cours doublé depuis la dernière mise à
jour économique ça ça rassure pas
beaucoup de gens puis en plus là c'est
en train de s'aligner vers une chicane
avec Québec je suis sûr que ça va bien
tourner cette chose là elle Chantale
effectivement il y a une PdA a réussi à
tirer son épingle du jeu puisse écouter
pendant plus cher qu'avant que ce qu'on
avait prévu est-ce que c'est le NPD qui
sont gagnants de l'exercice
c'est sûr que pour Jack meeting là le
programme d'assurance dentaire c'est un
gros lot c'est à dire c'est un résultat
tangible de son entente avec les
libéraux minoritaires et ça permet de
dire j'ai pas juste échanger trois
virgule dans des projets de loi j'ai
forcé les libéraux à mettre en place un
nouveau programme social c'est vrai que
ça fait tiquer les coûts du programme
d'assurance dentaire mais ça a tendance
à faire tiquer des gens qui s'en
serviront pas sur le terrain la réaction
est un petit peu différente et
s'incluent du Québec ou le programme est
nettement plus limité que n'importe quoi
qui est prévu par le programme fédéral
alors oui monsieur signe
de cette ronde de négociation budgétaire
quelque chose qui va apporter avec lui
qui va faire partie de son héritage qui
va lui permettre de dire en campagne
électorale vous voyez je sers à quelque
chose et en passant ces députés aussi
ont trouvé qui servait à quelque chose à
cause de l'influence du NPD sur le
budget alors oui c'était peut-être la
meilleure et la dernière meilleure
semaine de Monsieur sing partenaire de
Justin Trudeau en tout cas il était
content cette semaine on verra si
content
on verra évidemment
en tournée en tournée budgétaire pour
aller vendre son élément du budget c'est
quand même assez inhabituel pour un chef
de NPD de faire ça Hugo à Québec est-ce
qu'on est en train de se préparer pour
un affrontement là-dessus avec Ottawa
en tout cas très certainement disons que
c'est 13 milliards de dollars là en ce
qui concerne les soins dentaires c'est
rester en travers de la gorge du
ministre Girard ça c'est certain ami et
Girard dit ben on aurait dû investir
davantage en santé alors on a déjà vu un
peu la réaction de Justin Trudeau à
cette demande du Québec de se retirer
avec pleine compensation ferme pas la
porte mais en même temps on sent qu'il
va y avoir quand même pas mal de
conditions le cas échéant parce qu'on
voudra pas qu'on comprenne cet argent-là
pour le mettre en santé il va falloir
que ce soit utilisé pour les soins
dentaires là où le gouvernement fédéral
a marqué des points auprès du
gouvernement québécois c'est vraiment
c'est ça m'importantes le consenti aux
technologies vertes le ministre fait du
début lui-même disait qu'il s'inquiétait
c'est même que ça le privait de sommeil
certaines nuits le devoir le inflation
reduxon Act aux États-Unis il y avait
peur que des projets prévus au Québec
prennent le chemin justement des
États-Unis alors évidemment on a vu ça
d'un bon œil monsieur fait du Kevin va
peut-être un peu mieux dormir là c'est
somme importante qui sont mises de
l'avant en même temps le gouvernement
fédéral justement
le sucre d'eau a beaucoup mis l'accent
ces derniers temps là sur les minéraux
stratégiques la filière batterie un peu
une réponse à ceux qui le critiquaient
de pas avoir de politique économique
clair ça va pas vraiment le choix non
plus là dans ce contexte là d'aller de
l'avant avec une mesure comme ça il y
avait envoyé le message aussi monsieur
Trudeau lors de la visite de Monsieur
Biden là-dessus il nous reste 2 minutes
mais j'entends Michel je vous entendre
sur le volumineux rapport qui a été
déposé cette semaine suite à au massacre
de la tuerie de porte-à-pitre un nouvel
Écosse la GRC est suit la vaste majorité
des critiques dans ce rapport-là
qu'est-ce que ça veut dire pour la suite
des choses Michel Chantal ensuite
ça veut dire que pour une fois la GRC va
être obligé de faire quelque chose ou la
fois telle je ne sais pas mais ce qu'on
attend c'est qu'à chaque fois qu'il y a
eu un rapport comme ça sur la GR c'est
sur plusieurs aspects du travail de la
GRC que ce soit le service de sécurité
ou autre chose la GRC c'est retirer
l'ancien terme alors là j'imagine qu'au
gouvernement on va dire il faut faire
quelque chose et il y a dans la série
des recommandations des pistes assez
bien tracés c'est pas juste des
recommandations générales alors si
agercé ne réagit pas sur celle-là je me
demande ce que ça qu'est-ce que ça va
prendre et c'est que c'est effectivement
c'est quasiment il y a quasiment une
feuille de route là qu'il a été déposé
cette semaine Chantal qu'elle devrait
être la suite
en même temps que ce rapport c'est que
la personne qui a été nommée comme ça
intérimaire on va rester intérimaire et
pas trop longtemps parce que le point de
presse que suivi avec la déclaration
ouais j'ai reçu le rapport
de lire je vais le lire quand j'aurai le
temps
je disais à peu près tout sur ce sur
quoi cette commission a mis le doigt le
gouvernement doit nommer un ou une
nouvelle commissaire en chef la GRC sous
peu ça va être tout un mandat et entre
les deux il va falloir que
le gouvernement décide s'ils se rendre à
la recommandation de faire un examen
externe ou s'ils peuvent trouver
quelqu'un qui va trouver assez d'appui
au sein de la GRC pour faire des
changements qui s'imposent et ça va être
toute une commande et les commissaires
souhaiteraient que ça bouge d'ici la fin
du mois de mai on voudrait qu'il y a une
commission un organisme mise en place
justement pour faire avancer ces choses
là on va voir ce que ça va donner Hugo
Chantal Michel merci infiniment on se
voit pas pour pas qu'on se revoit la
semaine suivante